in the arena
there is no longer if you lose
everyone's gonna think that this is some
sort of big CGI feat that we managed to
construct but it's not at all should
have stayed away you should have killed
me I will
you decided very early on that every
time you see us with those horses
that's us with those horses it's
grounded and it's very real everything
very thorough they've built a full track
and we're actually pulling for real
horses on a chariot ride up I was very
proud of how dedicated everyone was to
safety and taking care of the animals we
actually work on both very strict set of
guidelines put forward by the American
Humane Association but make sure that
the horses are not overstretching
overuse for that reason no harm was done
to these horses you realize the dangers
every second but we have the best
trainers the best horses you always
thought you were in very safe hands
it's scary there's no air bags there are
no breaks it's like today's masks are
people enjoy the speed the attention
most of all when somebody will crash
you